[Música]
Hola qué tal Bienvenidos a este especial
deportivo de France 24 en el que como
cada final de año hacemos un repaso a
los y las deportistas más destacados de
los últimos 12 meses no es un ranking en
el que los deportistas aparezcan por
orden de importancia sino una selección
personal de nuestro equipo de deportes
junto a nuestros colaboradores
habituales en un año en que France 24 en
español ha ampliado más que nunca su
descubrimientos deportivos
y una de esas coberturas ha sido
precisamente la del mundial de fútbol de
Qatar 2022 que nos lleva a empezar de
nuevo este repaso como ya hiciéramos el
año pasado con Lionel Messi el Astro
argentino que si el 2021 lo acabó
ganando su primer título con Argentina
la Copa América este 2022 lo acaba con
el gran sueño de levantar el título de
campeón del mundo que lo coloca ya junto
a su ídolo Diego Armando Maradona en el
Olimpo del fútbol y lo hizo en una final
que pasará a la historia como una de las
mejores de todos los tiempos como broche
a este cubrimiento mundialista nuestro
enviado especial a Qatar Juan pupiales
nos comentaba todo lo que pudo ver ese
día de la final
Lionel Messi termina en el 2022 con su
sueño más preciado por fin con la
conquista de su copa mundo mundial siete
partidos que son suficientes para que
sea la Pulga el mejor futbolista de este
año 2022 un mes y que se consagra aquí
con esa tercera estrella en este estadio
de los hay el mismo estadio en donde
todo empezó a salir mal para la
albiceleste en esta copa mundo en ese
estadio fue en donde el conjunto
sudamericano debutó contra derrota
contra árabes ahorita pero fue también
aquí en ese partido contra México en
donde todo empezó a ir a bien un Messi
que realizó sin duda alguna su mejor
mundial 7 goles y tres asistencias un
mes y organizador o Messi repartidor o
Messi que da asistencia hace un Messi
definidor el Messi más goleador que
hemos visto en sus cinco participaciones
en Copa mundo y sobre todo un mes y
líder un mes y además casi como líder
espiritual líder anímico que convenció a
sus compañeros de que esta es su última
participación en los mundiales y los
convenció para darles energía y que
fueran ellos quienes le ayudaran a él a
conseguir ese sueño ese sueño que ya es
una realidad estar a la altura de los
grandes Messi que suma siete balones de
oro que suma también cuatro Champions
League y diez ligas españolas pero le
faltaba tocar la gloria con una copa
mundo al margen de este mundial Messi
que también ha completado una muy buena
parte de esta temporada 2022 2023 con su
Club con el París Saint suma once goles
en liga y en Champions League y en la
temporada pasada en el 2021-2022 que
comprende Todavía este año conquistó la
liga francesa y también la supercopa de
Francia sin duda alguna Messi completa
este año como el mejor entre los mejores
toca la gloria toca el cielo Ya con esa
copa mundo y está en esas mismas alturas
en donde está también ya subido los
Diego Armando Maradona
Juan pupiales desde
Qatar quien junto a nuestra otra enviada
especial allí al Mundial de Qatar
Natalia Ruiz giraldo hizo un gran
cubrimiento de este torneo y tuvieron la
suerte de Ver a Messi campeón del mundo
seguimos con más fútbol pero femenino
porque desde Colombia ha aparecido con
mucha fuerza en este 2022 un hombre muy
concreto el de la jugadora de tan solo
17 años linda Caicedo Que fue nombrada
mejor futbolista de la Copa América
femenina en la que Colombia recordemos
acabó segunda tan solo superada por
Brasil la delantera suena ya como
refuerzo de Clubes europeos con El
Fútbol Club Barcelona como principal
aspirante para hablar de linda Caicedo
conectamos con nuestra colaboradora
Estefanía Montero quien estuvo cubriendo
precisamente la Copa América femenina
para este canal Estefanía Por qué este
nombre sobre otras como Alexia putellas
y cuéntanos cómo ha sido el desarrollo
de linda Caicedo hasta ser un nombre tan
importante como a conseguir este 2022
Así es Rodrigo Sin lugar a duda el 2022
ha sido un año muy importante para el
fútbol femenino en Colombia y esto ha
permitido que una jugadora tan joven
como linda Caicedo pues hoy esté o esté
siendo nombrada al lado de Grandes
jugadoras como Alexia putellas eh
Incluso como otra referentes del punto
mundial yo creo que hay varias hay
varios aspectos a nombrar en el caso de
linda uno su juventud por supuesto es
unas diecisiete años y ni siquiera haber
cumplido la mayoría de edad cosa que no
le ha permitido tampoco llegar a Europa
pues es algo importante para el fútbol
femenino de Colombia Por qué Porque
linda fue subcampeona de la Copa América
siendo una jugadora juvenil pero que la
puso en la órbita mundial de jugadoras
que han competido mundiales incluso eh
Como la misma Alexa es el caso de una
jugadora que venía de ser campeona
nacional con su el deportivo Cali en el
2021 que no había podido disputar
incluso Copa Libertadores de América
cuando fue campeona en el 2019 con el
América de Cali también club de Colombia
y que poco a poco fue siendo nombrada a
nivel nacional y suramericano ahora con
las elecciones en marcha y con el
Campeonato o el mejor el torneo de la
Copa América en Colombia pues logró
catapultarse además con 17 años jugó
copa América de mayores mundial sub-20
en Costa Rica y fue subcampeona mundial
sub-17 si bien son torneos juveniles
pero que pusieron en la órbita a Linda
Caicedo del mundo es una jugadora que
ha mencionado Incluso el presidente del
Fútbol Club Barcelona por eh que lo
adquieren que es de su Estilo Y por qué
no acá en Colombia decimos que tiene un
estudio también muy parecido
a alpino Faustino asprilla o incluso
también esos regates y ese juego de El
Lionel Messi hoy también campeón del
mundo
sin lugar a duda linda Caicedo es hoy
una jugadora referente tanto que la
federación internacional de historia y
estadística del fútbol la ha considerado
la jugadora juvenil la mejor jugadora
juvenil del 2022 Pues un gran año desde
luego para linda Caicedo y Estefanía
vamos a aprovechar para contarles a
nuestros espectadores que también eres
directora de comunicación en la
federación colombiana de natación una
oportunidad de oro para hablar de
nuestra siguiente deportista del año se
trata de las nadadoras estadounidense
Katy le deceki una leyenda ya de la
natación por su abortado medallero
olímpico y sus 19 títulos mundiales
Estefanía qué más se puede decir a estas
alturas del edeki y en qué ha destacado
especialmente este año
le de aquí viene siendo de esas figuras
del deporte mundial que sorprenden desde
muy joven a sus quince años Fue campeona
olímpica incluso fue campeona olímpica
antes de ser campeona mundial y pues en
este año no dejó medalla suelta como
podríamos decir
la estadounidense fue al mundial fina en
budapest en mitad de año en junio y
consiguió cuatro títulos mundiales
cuatrocientos metros libres 800 metros
libre 1500 Y el relevo de cuatro por
doscientos en la modalidad también libre
Lee x sigue sumando eh récord sigue
sumando eh más triunfos para los
estadounidenses por supuesto quienes hoy
la consideran la Michael femenina es que
tiene apenas 24 años y ya disputado tres
Juegos Olímpicos Incluso se podría
hablar que puede llegar a disputar hasta
seis Juegos Olímpicos lo que consideran
una locura además es una nadadora de
fondo como pueden ver son las pruebas
más largas de la natación lo que le
permite leer y también manejar un poco
los tiempos en las pruebas de fondo es
mucho más fácil bajar los tiempos que en
una prueba velocidad y además hace dos
meses en el último trimestre del año X
logró convertirse en la recordista
mundial de piscina corta piscina corta
recordemos es la modalidad de 25 metros
se compite Generalmente en 50 la piscina
corta tiene la mitad de esta longitud
800 metros es el récord mundial que
obtuvo en la copa mundo de natación de
piscina corta en Estados Unidos el
tiempo siete minutos cincuenta y siete
segundos cuarenta y dos centésimas ahora
bien en Canadá en la copa noventa y dos
logró un nuevo récord los mil quinientos
metros de piscina corta con quince
minutos ocho segundos veinticuatro
centésimas la x tiene los récords de los
Y dos mil quinientos metros tanto en
piscina de 50 metros como en piscina de
25 metros lo que la convierte por
supuesto en una leyenda absoluta de la
natación mundial pues Estefanía estamos
seguros de que habrá que seguir muy
atentos a ledecky muchas gracias por
participar en nuestro resumen del año
con los 10 deportistas que hemos elegido
vamos ahora con varios atletas que
participan en disciplinas clásicas del
atletismo el primero de ellos es el
sueco Armando planties a sus 23 años ya
es todo un referente en El Salto con
pértiga con unos números que asustan
tiene el actual récord del mundo con
seis metros y 21 centímetros de altura
pero es que ha conseguido este año batir
en tres ocasiones el récord mundial
además de proclamarse campeón del mundo
al aire libre y en pista cubierta para
analizar su temporada conectamos con
Juan José sayago quien este año cubrió
para France 24 el Campeonato del mundo
de atletismo Juanjo qué suponen estos
récords de duplantis tanto en El Salto
con pértiga como en el atletismo en
general y donde podría estar el techo de
este atleta estamos hablando de un
atleta que apenas acaba de cumplir 23
años en noviembre de este 2022 y que en
Precisamente en esta temporada tuvo 18
victorias de 19 participaciones es decir
apenas una derrota en todo lo que vivió
Armando blandis Durante este año en el
que Precisamente en ese campeonato
mundial de Oregón consigue el tope en
cuanto a las marcas personales de todas
las que rompió durante 2022
que tú mencionabas fueron todos los
récords batidos para duplantis en su
disciplina en El Salto con pértiga que
para que tengan una idea en la próxima
marca mínima que ha exigido en cuanto a
esta modalidad para los Juegos Olímpicos
de París
20242 y su registro máximo es de 6 con
21 hablamos de esta Campaña en la que se
batieron absolutamente todos los récords
tanto de pista cubierta como al aire
libre lo logró Armando plantis en Serbia
en par de oportunidades poniendo seis
metros con 20 y también mejorando en
cuanto a una competencia muy importante
como la liga de diamantes en la que
terminó con seis dieciséis en estocolmo
venciendo un récord que era precisamente
de él terminó el europeo con un seis
cero seis pero antes ahí en Oregon puso
lo que hoy conocemos como el récord del
mundo esos seis veintiunos una marca muy
importante para duplantis es que saltó
seis o más metros durante esta temporada
en 23 ocasiones precisamente son 23 años
que son los con los que cuenta hoy el
sueco nacido en los Estados Unidos pues
Juanjo quiero hacerte otra pregunta
sobre otra atleta un referente también
en el atletismo es tu compatriota de
yulimar rojas que Ya apareció en esta
lista el año pasado sus oros Olímpicos y
mundiales Por qué debía aparecer yulimar
rojas también sobre otras atletas este
año
aparecer por haber sido tan consistente
durante toda la temporada A diferencia
de signos
rojas sí participó en la Liga de
diamantes y en cuanto evento pudo haber
estado la venezolana que además de
lograr el récord mundial bajo techo
logró coronar también su sexto título
mundial ahí Precisamente en Oregón ese
récord del mundo de bajo techo que
ocurrió en el mundial de Belgrado en
este año 2022 fue de 15,74 metros en
yulimar rojas desde que tomó la corona
de reina del salto triple mundial lo que
ha hecho es superarse a sí misma en
todas las competencias en la que ha
participado quizás la única deuda fue la
no participación en El Salto largo por
una diferencia con los zapatos que
ocurrió precisamente antes del mundial
pero de recto ganó absolutamente todo y
quizás por eso Más allá del aspecto
técnico que se toma para darle
finalmente el la corona de mejor atleta
para jugar athletics de Cinema Club creo
que esa consistencia de yulimar rojas
durante esta temporada de 2022 es lo que
en lo personal creo que
debió permitirle meterse allí dentro de
las mejores del mundo recordemos que
yulimar en el récord olímpico también
con 1567 que lo logró el primero de
agosto del año 2021 en los Juegos
Olímpicos de Tokio 2020 y que desde ese
momento no se ha bajado del centro más
importante para las saltadoras de Triple
en todo el mundo pues Juan José sayago
también quiero agradecerte a ti que
estés con nosotros en este especial de
Navidad y Desde luego por tu cobertura
de ese mundial de atletismo para France
24 seguimos ahora con otra mujer en este
ranking es además la primera mujer
brasileña en convertirse en campeona del
mundo de gimnasia artística estamos
hablando de Rebeca Andrade de tan solo
23 años también y ya subcampeona
olímpica en los juegos de Tokio este año
se impuso con autoridad en el mundial
celebrado en Liverpool en Reino Unido
con esta Victoria con 1,5 puntos sobre
la estadounidense si les echo Jones
confirmó que era la favorita llevarse el
título hablamos con nuestra periodista
deportiva humana sobre la brasileña
eumar Cómo ha sido la carrera de la
brasileña para llegar hasta este punto
estamos hablando de la primera atleta no
solo brasileña sino además Sudamericana
y latinoamericana que logra un podio en
la prueba de General individual el all
round que es la que la que Corona a la
más completa de las competidoras en la
gimnasia la que destaca más en todo lo
hizo en el Campeonato del mundo de
Liverpool y es muy importante entender
que esto es un atleta que viene de seis
años prácticamente perdidos en su
carrera por lesiones ella se rompió tres
veces el ligamento anterior cruzado de
la pierna derecha en 2015-2017 2019 y
creo que es muy importante que después
de su año de consagración que fue el año
de 2021 en los Juegos Olímpicos ella
pueda mantener pueda tener continuidad
en sus resultados que digamos no fue una
estrella fulgurante que salió en el
momento sino que es la nueva dominadora
y la más completa de la gimnasia ahí
Brasil tiene precedentes de atletas que
han subido lo más alto del podio en
Campeonato del mundo caso Arthur zanetti
pero en anillas caso dayanne dos Santos
en piso pero esta corona de la más
completa solo le pertenece a Rebeca
Andrade que además es la única atleta
brasileña que ha logrado coronarse en
dos pruebas diferentes porque ella
recordemos en el mundial pasado ganó el
Salto al potro y Omar sin intentar
desmerecer en ningún momento este
grandísimo Triunfo de Andrade Es verdad
que ha llegado sin la participación de
las atletas rusas que suponen no tener a
las gimnastas rusas en este tipo de
torneos Es una muy buena pregunta porque
podemos comparar
por atleta con las integrantes de ese
equipo ruso que ganó la medalla de oro
por equipos en los Juegos Olímpicos de
Tokio que fue la última vez que
aparecieron en competencias la penúltima
después del Campeonato del mundo en
competencias internacionales de gimnasia
luego quedaron suspendidas Lilia a
jaimova integrante de ese equipo está
hoy retirada no hubiera sido competencia
para Rebeca Elena gerasimo es un atleta
de proyección juvenil Anastasia un
especialista en barras asimétricas no es
tan completa como Rebeca Andrade
Victoria
es más o menos el caso de querasimo a un
atleta de proyección viene de coronarse
campeón europea en la general individual
pero todavía no ha brillado a nivel
mundial y la última la más digamos
brillante de Esta generación rusa que es
Angelina ganó un bronce en la general
individual de Tokio O sea ya estaba por
debajo en esa oportunidad de Rebeca
Andrade que ahí fue plata pues muchas
gracias sumar por este repaso deportivo
y Gracias por todo el trabajo que has
hecho Durante este 2022 nosotros
seguimos desde este estudio con el que
en su momento fue el niño prodigio de la
Fórmula 1 que ya el año pasado apareció
en esta lista por haber conseguido su
primer mundial se trata del neerlandés
de La escudería Red Bull Max verstappen
que en este 2022 se consolidó como
bicampeón del mundo Con un fuerte
dominio sobre su máximos rivales entre
ellos su compañero de equipo el mexicano
Checo Pérez y eso que al principio de
año parecía que Ferrari los del cavalino
rampante las escudería italiana podría
romper este dominio de Red Bull de los
últimos años en la Fórmula 1 empezaron
el año más fuertes que los del Toro rojo
tenían buen motor y un coche rompedor en
aerodinámico además de una dupla muy
fuerte con Charles leclerc y Carlos
Sainz pero poco a poco fueron
apareciendo los problemas de fiabilidad
y táctica en Ferrari y ahí estaba
verstappen para aprovecharlo porque el
neerlandés no sólo Ha ganado el título
sino que ha roto el registro histórico
de victorias en una sola temporada un
total de 15 por las 13 que tenían mijael
schumacher y Luis Hamilton es un ganador
nato con mucha hambre de Victoria y lo
demostró cuando aseguró que no iba a
dejar ganar a su compañero checo en su
casa en México también superó a Hamilton
en puntos totales en una sola temporada
de Fórmula 1 hace tiempo que verstappen
ya dejó de ser el niño prodigio para ser
el presente y seguramente el futuro de
la Fórmula 1 habrá que ver si Ferrari en
este próximo 2023 sus ventas sus
problemas de fiabilidad Y si leclerc
consigue minimizar sus errores porque
ambos están llamados desde hace tiempo a
protagonizar las luchas de esta nueva
generación de pilotos hay un tercero
Carlos Sainz quien También puede estar
ahí pese a no haber logrado su mejor
temporada en el Horizonte aparece
también la nueva joya de Mercedes el
británico George Russell por el momento
nadie está siendo capaz de quitarle las
pegatinas al bicampeón Marx verstappen
y la siguiente protagonista que quisimos
destacar viene también de la región
suramericana se trata de la primera
mujer ecuatoriana en conseguir una
medalla olímpica estoy hablando de
nazisy dajomes una mujer que ha
conseguido este año grandes logros
después de haber tenido también un gran
2021 en los Juegos Olímpicos ahora su
mirada está puesta ya en 2023 en los
juegos de París y también en los juegos
suramericanos para hablar de neisy de
James tenemos ya a nuestro periodista de
deportes Luis Méndez urich
resiliencia es una palabra que cuando
nos pregunten Quién es neisy dajomes
debe estar en su definición años atrás
esta atleta era recordada por
desplomarse en una competencia
internacional pero gracias a su trabajo
a su esfuerzo a su dedicación logró
cambiar esa historia y convertirse en la
primera mujer de Ecuador que gana una
medalla olímpica y lo hizo en los juegos
de Tokio en la división de los 76 kg de
peso de la halterofilia una disciplina
en la que participa desde que tuvo su
primer acercamiento a los 11 años de
edad en Tokio se colgó el oro pero más
allá de ese éxito neisy Ya puso su
mirada en lo que será su próximo gran
reto los Juegos Olímpicos de París en el
año 2024 y para ello inició su ciclo
olímpico de la mejor manera consiguiendo
medalla de oro en su primera parada en
los juegos bolivarianos de valledupar
Colombia Pero allí no participó en la
división de los 76 kilogramos sino que
subió a la división 81 kilogramos no
sólo logró colgarse el oro sino que
además implementó un nuevo récord para
la competencia un nuevo récord para
Suramérica y además un récord
Panamericano pero esta alegría se
extendió a octubre donde participó en
los juegos sudamericanos realizados en
Asunción Paraguay allí subió a los 87
kilogramos de peso y pudo también
colgarse la medalla de oro Estableciendo
nuevos recursos para la competencia y
para Sudamérica esto al conseguir 115
kilogramos en el arranque y 135 en el
embrión para un total de 250 kilogramos
Daisy cerró el año en la ciudad de
Bogotá participando en la Copa del Mundo
de la disciplina allí regresó a la
división de los 81 kg pero solamente
pudo captar El quinto lugar en una
prueba que fue dominada por las atletas
de China y en donde su compañera de
equipo Tamara Salazar logró colarse en
el con el tercer lugar pero neisy ya
tiene su mirada fijada también en lo que
será el año 2023 y el Magno evento para
los atletas de la región como lo es los
Juegos Panamericanos de Santiago allí
neisy con sus credenciales con sus
registros tiene voluntad para soñar y a
un país detrás de ella que la está
impulsando a ser no solo la atletas más
laureada de la historia de esa nación
sino una de las más recordadas dentro
del continente y cerramos este repaso a
los mejores deportistas del año con el
ciclismo un deporte en el que me atrevo
a decir que tenemos sin duda a una de
las deportistas más destacadas entre los
destacados del panorama mundial se trata
de otra neerlandesa la ciclista del
Movistar Team anemiak van Floyd quien a
sus 40 años es el referente absoluto en
el ciclismo femenino y es que en un
mismo año consiguió el triplete de giro
de Italia Tour de Francia y vuelta a
España Y para rematar consiguió su
segundo título de campeona mundial para
analizar su figura tenemos a nuestro
periodista especializado en ciclismo y
en el pulseguí bienvenido leonil Lionel
ponnos un poco en contexto Cómo ha sido
la temporada de vamploid en Más allá de
lo que he comentado es una temporada
excepcional como tú lo comentabas de
ganar Las tres grandes vueltas y además
desde el campeona del mundo es la prueba
de creo que del esfuerzo del trabajo y
de una atleta de una deportista que es
increíble en su capacidad física para
lograr lo que logró este año hay un
elemento muy fuerte
paran es que es muy perfeccionista pero
tiene una capacidad física para las
cargas de trabajo que es increíble y que
para una mujer nunca se ha visto te doy
un ejemplo y una cifra ella Se entrena
sobre más de 30.000 kilómetros al año
como ciclista que son cifras que
normalmente vemos para los hombres y
nunca para mujeres las mujeres se
entrenan entre 20.000 25.000 máximo
kilómetros al año ella los 30.000 esa
cifra le da una ventaja de resistencia
en las carreras que es mucho más fuerte
que las otras que sus rivales y que las
otras ciclistas y es también el creo que
la experiencia que de llegar a 40 años
saber lo donde son sus puntos fuertes y
por ejemplo su su condición física que
superior de los otros que nos puede
explicar un poquito este fenómeno que es
excepcional en el ciclismo desde luego
es la más veterana del pelotón femenino
Pero quizás eso lo utiliza como una
ventaja Lionel vamos a seguir ahora con
otro ciclista masculino es un joven de
18 años perdón 18 años más joven que
vamploiten podríamos llamarle el
renacido el ciclismo no es otro que el
belga Bene pool nuevo campeón del mundo
y de la vuelta a España también quien
confirmó las expectativas que hay
puestas sobre él como uno de los nombres
que pueden marcar época en este deporte
lío había dudas sobre su capacidad luego
de haber tenido un gravísimo accidente
una serie de dos años en Italia en el
giro de lombardía cómo ha llegado renco
bennetpull Qué tipo de ciclista es ahora
es tomen un ciclista de excepcional era
una promesa de este deporte del ciclismo
era una promesa grande en Bélgica que
siempre está esperando su nuevo campeón
quizás que ya lo tiene
es un fenómeno porque hace 5 años estaba
jugando fútbol a los 17 años todavía
estaba jugando fútbol Esperando ser de
futbolista profesional y a los 22 años
es el mejor ciclista del año para
nosotros y para mucha gente se ganó
también la bicicleta de oro que es el
equivalente del Balón de oro en el
fútbol y lo lo logra por su talento y de
confirmar algo que
no sabíamos exactamente que era si era
en capacidad o no de ganar una gran
vuelta de tres semanas le habíamos visto
muy fuerte sobre carreras de un día
sobre clásicas pero muy limitados sobre
la última semana de una gran vuelta
que sea el Tour de Francia por ejemplo o
este año sobre la vuelta de España había
esas duras lo logró y demostró que a 22
años ya es dentro de los mejores
ciclistas de Esta generación que es
también increíble y que él Quizás va a
pelear las otras grandes porque anunció
que el año que viene va a Corea del giro
de italiano pues muchas gracias Lionel
por este repaso estaremos atentos a que
a lo que pueda hacer panderpool perdone
en el giro de Italia Gracias por
acompañarnos en este especial de fin de
año de deportes en France 24 sigan con
nuestra programación
[Música]